[Music]
all right
you know how we're all in this pandemic
and we are what pandemic
we are all required to wear face
coverings right like
have you guys stopped to think
think about the kids that are not 21 yet
who can actually take advantage of this
pandemic and go into a liquor store
and buy liquor with their fake id
and they don't actually have to prove
that it's them because they're wearing a
face cover i have something
i just take the cover i took my cover
off when i was buying alcohol and
they're like no
no no oh yeah and i was like but how do
you know
yeah you're like we don't care we want
to make the sale
no [ __ ] they closed our businesses
down we need money i aged out of that
but i have been using my other fake id
that says i'm 74.
and i've been taking advantage of my
senior citizen privileges
nice yeah go on there i keep getting
these scenes i see the wrinkles i
wouldn't question
oh i see it too my dad looks like
super young i'm like how that how do you
think your daddy looks
well i mean he's got some gray now but
but he
he's young for his eight yeah like i
think he looks like
50 or a couple years younger and he's
over 55 so he gets he's like proud he
gets his
aarp like discount so he's like i get
the deal yeah so he's not offended he's
like i don't care if i look
i just get the deal no he says that he's
like yeah and they don't believe me so i
have to show them improvement oh
that's what you said that's what nikki
will do too yeah
she already loves it when she when she
gets
carded yeah she loves it dude you gotta
do that tick tock thing then
where the it's a voice over and you just
sit there and then they're like uh
people usually think that you're younger
than you are and then you tell them your
age
that's true remember that surfer girl
that was so proud when she was asking us
how
old we were and i'm like she was like oh
my god you're 30 something no way she
goes
me too i'm only 23. we were like
what like you look 40. like what the
hell what happened out there
she looked like really joined the young
looking
crowd and then we're looking at her like
girl you look 40 something
oh that's the thing the surfing in the
sun was not good to you
it's the sun bro sun ages you yeah like
we come back with good tans but the
if we did that every [ __ ] day dude
yeah it does it doesn't matter what your
ethnic makeup is you're you're gonna
look [ __ ] up it's also depending on
like
your city and like community that you're
you're living in because like
if everybody's going in the sun all the
time and you happen to look younger than
them then you're
then you're all oh you think you're
thinking you're weird comparative you're
like oh i look really young
but then if you go to another place
where everybody looks super young
well dude there's a thing in san diego
where i call them jacuzzi dads
and they look like they got baked out
there are the orange guys
yeah because they get all orange because
they love to sit in the sun and they
wear tommy bahama shirts
and you know it's just there's some
leather ladies out there another ladies
[Laughter]
oh my gosh like in the beach towns like
it's they look like the lady from um
uh [ __ ] they got bright bleach blonde
something about mary yeah thank you
oh yeah that lady but like it'll be 12
30
in the just in the morning right like
afternoon and they're like should i warm
up the jacuzzi it's like dude
[ __ ] the day just started bro what
are you talking about like
it's like that i could be jacuzzi any
time of the day
exactly you could be i'm gonna be that
jacuzzi dad dude
that's gonna be joe well right now on
tick tock there's this
there's a lot of videos that are going
up of teens
going into liquor stores buying liquor
with their fake id
oh they're so small or like or because
there's a lot of bling's id
or cousins like it's either it's either
they're using a fake id
and they don't have to show their face
or they are actually dressing themselves
as like
old people that's smart and then they're
covering half their face so they just
have to sell like this part so i'm gonna
show you
one of these tick tocks where these
girls are dressing up and they're trying
out this
prank to see if it works okay a legal
prank
prank yeah oh my god we're totally gonna
commit a crime
[Music]
so it worked damn they're gonna get
caught isn't that just
documenting a crime that's what i'm
saying they're like kids that don't
there's a lot of kids on tick tock doing
this right now
so it's fine that's that's hilarious
because it's like we're gonna go rob a
bank and then you go dude
[Applause]
they're putting a gun in the banker guys
yeah no they're putting a gun in the
bank guy's mouth and they're like
suck it like it's a [ __ ] dick or blow
out
[Laughter]
you guys man you're making it work and
you're actually getting yourself because
man
back in back in the day we'd have to
have like an older sibling
to you guys stand by at 7 11 and wait
for a crackhead to come up that's what
i'm saying i'm finding a [ __ ] way
that's working bottle two so it's like
we'll pay for a bottle for you
if you just get us bottles too all the
clerks are like
so stupid like they could see right
through it they're not getting paid
enough
like all people don't have silver hair
this even or this
[ __ ] plastic or this netted [ __ ]
net all around
yeah they'd be better off if they just
used their regular faces and just
created wrinkles around their eyes like
some crow's feet or something well
some people are doing that and like some
people get like for example this chick
she used a whole ass walker and like she
put some grapes oh my god
right in the front that's so good crazy
here that's pretty good that's pretty
good that's actually pretty good
it works she's like oh just trying to
buy that just trying to get some mike's
hard lemonade
and then they choose some holidays
oh i'm just judging me just buying some
hypnotic you know
oh my god you know what we old people
drink these are so [ __ ] teen alcohols
boon farm what's that sour apple one
it's like this this this midori no
smeared off sour oh when i look at it i
think of vomiting heat schnapps
geez but yeah i'm telling you they're
literally just they're going in there
pretending buying all the white clothes
yeah buying up all the white claws the
young people drinks
here's a different one
dang there you go at least you got the
cheap cab that's smart i don't know if i
would be excited that i passed as an old
person because i'd be like damn
do i look [ __ ] up i wouldn't give a
[ __ ] i'd be like i got alcohol
on the system when you're that age you
just want it it's so hard for me that i
just huffed out above a balloon yes
exactly that's why i'm like props to you
guys
just like i was drinking hairspray out
of the air
you had to spray it in the air and you
had to lick it up the air conditioner
that's exactly exactly accurate because
i could not get alcohol
yeah we used to just steal it just like
we used to drink the little bit of drip
off the back of the air conditioner oh
cause it's coming down we're like
hey get out of the way give me some
literally computer cleaner i'm not proud
yeah like when whenever you guys did
beer runs wasn't it just
running in and stealing them no i
thought that's what a beer run was
to get to get uh rested
i was too sweet a kid man never did
anything i did have one
my boyfriend's best friend at the time
he did that once and i was
so scared and so ashamed that i couldn't
even drink from it because i was like
it's totally gonna incriminate me yeah i
felt like there was so many ways to get
cigarettes and alcohol when you're a kid
like you you can ask the local bum
you could ask somebody's drunk brother
that's the
great way you wait by the 7-eleven and
then when you know
jerry the crackhead comes in and you
could be like hey jerry check this out i
got money i'll buy
cigarettes and whatever yeah just go in
there buy me some alcohol
and then he'll get you right but if
jerry's not around
then what do you do you got to get
creative as a youngin yeah exactly then
what do you do joe
you dress up like a grandma during a pen
that's way better
oh you steal with honor yeah you go to a
big
company like a grocery store and then
you can't do this now because they have
them locked in cages or like
you know on top of the bottles they had
those sensor things now
but when um i was a youngin and i'd even
like drinking
but then my friends like we want a drink
and i was like okay fine and then we
would have
pants where it was baggy but at the
bottom
it would um we would tie with rubber
bands
so then uh when we was a style actually
that was a style but we did it like
empty hammer pants and then it covered
over
so then at the ankle it gets stuck and
then we would just do one of these
and then it drops all the way down you
can put like two jose cuervos or
whatever
you're walking around clunking away
smart
basically you just walk away yeah i have
big calves
but yeah and then i thought whenever
people said beer runs that's what they
did
it's like everyone literally ran yeah
we're going for a beer run
like let's do a beer run guys and you go
in and then guys just
take the beer or what alcohol and they
run right yeah
i hung out with older people so they
would just buy it for me
yeah but when i say older you know with
[ __ ] 15 year olds
what a loser that is like but you look
cool oh i guess
that's true huh when you're with older
people you think you're so
but then you realize the older person
that i got with you they were the losers
yeah crazy because i had this guy
driving me to prom
and i'm like well and i was like man
he's so cool and then now i'm like what
a [ __ ] loser because i wouldn't have
done that
no hell no when as soon as i turned 18 i
was like
i'm trying to chill with 20 year olds
yeah
not these 15 year olds you guys all had
friends
yeah we have so many friends
wait i wish i would left my house i
didn't know any eight 21 year olds at
like 15 or 14 the old guys were 18. well
i knew the guys who grad
they just graduated and then they were
still in like kind of the drama circle
unfortunately still like 19.
right so but they had just graduated
right yeah and then they were able to
get it
easily like through whoever the [ __ ] oh
because the 18 year olds knew 21 year
olds
yeah because we had to wait for my
friend's brother to come home and
thinking like
i'm just never going to turn 21. like
it's just so far away it's so
it feels forever though yeah but then as
soon as i turned 21
i blink and i'm 30. oh and the 30s go
so much faster don't tell me that girl
they really do because i do
i turned 30 like yesterday and now i'm
turning 34 this year and i'm like
what the [ __ ] i like basically graduated
high school again
from 30 to 34. well plus i like that
nothing happened plus time flies when
you're drinking like printer cleaner and
[ __ ]
really does it's a different thing we
don't have the same brand now i
understand why
like people that are in their 60s and on
they just forget their age
yeah they'll just be like oh you're
gonna make me count all right hold on
seriously i
i mean i'm only 30 sometimes i forget
and and when your birthday is the end of
the year i always think i'm the age that
i'm about to turn
yeah saying just turn yeah you just turn
it and then as soon as a new year
happens you're like oh i'm going to turn
this
this year so the whole year i think i'm
the next stage
why does why do things go faster is it
fun
is it relative to your life experience
so for example right like
if you've only lived till 20 right then
that means 10 years is half of your life
so it feels like a lot but if you lived
up to 30
then 10 years is only a third of your
life so yeah relative to perspective
of how much time and also like how much
stress you have i think i think it's a
stress
yeah oh because we are stressed out when
we were younger
yeah but then it's a different kind of
it's way different because i'm blind of
how bad it is yes
that is it think about when quarantine
started right quarantine started
were we talking about march right now
yeah like it's [ __ ] july guys
like it's almost august i can't even
believe it
by the time this video comes out i'll
probably be august sorry mine has blown
the [ __ ] by and also been slow as [ __ ]
at the same time and i can't
i feel like it's been slower it's only
been fast for me
it's both yeah i'm with you both i don't
i can't
explain it something confusing we have a
big family calendar in our own
refrigerator and like i exit out and i'm
like what the [ __ ]
it's fast slow exactly that's it fast
flow or slow fast
fast fast have you guys taken it slow
have you guys ever taken it slow for
like a week
and then go yeah that felt longer than a
week yeah no
i don't know how to take it slow there's
too many things happening all the time
i'm like
i just wish that i could sleep forever
no there are days where i wake up
and then next thing i know i'm going
back to bed i'm like what the [ __ ] did
what just happened this whole day i
can't even go back to bed no more
what do you go back to you do i just get
up
get up twice no i'm saying i wake up in
the morning and then i find myself going
back
like going to sleep at night and i
didn't realize the whole [ __ ] day
just went by and i'm like what just
happened
oh ollie may you wake up so fast go back
to bed
does anyone else have like a ticking
timer in their head too like when i wake
up i'm like
it's 9 a.m already oh my god it's only
three hours till 12 and then like
and then oh that means it's only five
hours till this and then i'm just
thinking in terms of how long it's gonna
get me always yeah it's just counting
down
and you're like 10 30 that's only an
hour and a half till 12. oh my god
that's stressful yeah why i have that
because i have my mom
so my mom leaves at a certain hour so
i'm like [ __ ] i gotta jam packed this
whole [ __ ] before
my mom and i also have taika or a timer
thing it's like
oh i have to have this in by five oh my
god it's almost 12 and then that's
only five hours till five
foreign